where did the idea for farting video
come from oh I don't know no one's ever
laughed at a fart or done anything with
parts before well actually that's not
true we haven't put out a video in a
long time we haven't we got to make
something something and what is that
what's that what's the dark arts of VFX
and I think the dark arts of the effects
is to use these advanced fumefx
techniques and all this advanced
simulation just to have someone fart and
make it gross and funny on screen not
everyone of our video ideas works out
like this but a lot of ideas will come
from us thinking of an effect or a
technique or some little thing that
would look funny on film and the
challenge from there is actually like
writing a story around it so for example
with this idea is hey we can make really
funny fart scenes it's like well what's
the story one-upsmanship and that's you
know kind of Halloween so for the fart
effects we use something called fluid
simulations and specifically we use fume
effects which is a plugin for 3ds max
now a fume effects it's obviously one of
the best ones out there in my opinion
and I guess Sam's pinyin - what do you
think Sam I had a great time making
parts with it yeah it's the best
so do you effects you have something
called emitter and that's basically how
we did this videos I made cube effects
emitters generally like tracked it to
people's butts by hand and then you just
set it to emit a certain amount of smoke
at a certain amount of speed and then in
FEMA facts you can go on you can control
the quality you can control the density
control the color and many other little
very yes we rendered all of ours at high
quality some of the tricks that you can
do to get really good looking smoke
simulations is crank your quality way
high but that makes it take like hours
and hours to sim but it's worth it next
thing you can do is you can add a little
bit of turbulence or system so like that
right we do your simulation right at the
beginning of a little bit turbulence it
makes everything like when spin in a
normal fashion but inside the computer
there's no turbulence there's no wind
it's like a perfect quiet vacuum of a
room so you MIT smoke it just like has
this really unnatural like dome that
just like rises up so you like make it
look like it's real you get some
turbulence maybe add wind add some like
objects for the bounce off of you know
that somebody's moving you want to put
like some sort of model in there to
reference them so it's like swishing
through the smoke all these little
things that like mimic the real world
make it look realistic where things
start getting crazy is with our friend
Dee's shot where he does a double jump
fart Andy he's just just cleaned up
we're making some cool combine solider
costumes nobody knows yet we basically
filmed a normal plate of just him
running and doing a normal double jump
on the ground and what we did is we a
normal double jump the normal Dylan aka
running like this running jumping
landing he double jumps on the ground
hops twice and what we did is we cut him
out we replaced the background and then
basically animate this stabilized
chopped out rotoscoped version of him to
double jump and then on top of that we
do a little FEMA pack simulation and a
little little to trail that goes over
with him that's about it as far as a
Niko's shot that comes next his shots
broken down into two sections his first
shot where he comes flying in like a
like a Harrier jet basically Nikko is
filmed on a stool on a green screen and
what I'm doing is I'm basically walking
around orbiting the camera to mimic the
perspective shift of him coming towards
the camera now the second one where
Nikko is kind of coming in for the
landing hovers and jumps off his little
fart we do something totally different
there's no green screen work he's just
sitting on that exact same stool but in
the beginning of the shot to make it
look like he's still floating what we're
doing is we're replacing the entire
background again cutting him out
rotoscoping him and just giving his
individual Lahti it's just a little bit
of that hovering motion before then
cutting back into the real shot where he
continues his actions and interacts with
this as well what makes a great VFX
artist is somebody who doesn't just
technically know how to do something and
make it look real it's somebody who can
bring artistry to it and bring character
to whenever they're happening to work on
so for example when I'm flying in acting
all cool and floating on my farts the
very first render we had was I just zip
on down a diagonal line and arrived by
the camera great looks real it works
technically proficient but not a great
shot yet it becomes a great shot when
it's given a little bit of character and
for example if you look at it now I come
in floating and some of my parts cut out
and I drop
little bit and I catch it and hover back
in and it has just like a little story
to it just like a second long
it gives it personality it gets a
character and the more you can bring
that into your effect shots when you
take them just you want to take them
away from just being technical effects
you want to give them little bits of
artistry and character and personality
and the more you do that the better your
effect shots become there's one shot in
the piece
whereas antic slider puts it behind him
and his butt explodes but let's loop
those all the times you're saying boot
for that shot no need to do it with
effects let's do it for real
we have my stunt shorts that I wore
during the shoot we're going to put a
little bomb here and we're gonna blow it
up in slow motion and it all give you
one percent real and school looks sweet
I scored the pants a little bit so the
explosion rips through them a little
more easily you can see here and also
these shorts are to simulate the bum
cheeks you have to throw these up here
and put the explosion between the butt
cheeks essentially so that's the way
it's going to look the most realistic is
the fs700 here it's a camera I can do
super slow-motion not that
laser beam in my eyes ah okay are you
worried about your safety no um because
I'm not gonna be here filming it I'm
just gonna I'm going to let it start
buffering I'm gonna run away we're gonna
blow it up and run back and stop the
buffering hey camera familiar what is
that my camel here we go guys why is my
camera the ones next East Asian trigger
okay here we go three two one perfect no
that literally was perfect that's what
you wanted yeah exactly
okay okay we get a little food mostly
smoke oh good it's good luck yeah and it
made a big give me the right size hole
yeah I know
now you'll notice Sam's hand is in that
shot now that'd be silly Sam would hurt
himself with his hand was actually in
the shot so we did for that take home
Sam's hand on a green screen holding a
lighter and he pulls another shot really
quick that little touch makes that shot
seem much more alive and much more real
because otherwise you'd probably be able
to tell it's just a pair of shorts on
PVC pipe yeah arm aches and let me see
my hand in there you get fooled
Sam's rocket parts part to the
stimulation go Niko all right so for
this case I use to connect and did a 3d
scan of Sam work the same way we did it
in uh headhunters so basically it's the
same stuff like this um hands out or
whatever and we could put his hands on
too much because they wobble and then
like as he scanned it in things such a
like shift a little bit you get like
weird mutant arms so we had to keep him
a little bit lower so he stable imagine
Niko's me and Niko's going like this the
way it seems like it's like trying to
scan a barcode and it doesn't really
work very well and just keep doing it
over and over again until it looks good
so anyways scan and same with the Kinect
cleaned it up a little bit used to wrap
it to generate a very clean mesh and
this mesh I brought into Mudbox
and then I took a bunch of pictures of
Sam at the camera wearing the same
outfit that he just wore when a scan
in with the Kinect and I textured it by
hand it's actually not that hard you
just basically project the pictures onto
Sam from whichever angles they were
taken from so after this was all done I
used a program called endorphin instead
of a simulation of Sam McGee rocketed
into a wall when he hits it and they
like curls up and hits the ground it's
really cool and I brought that back into
3dsmax applied it as motion capture data
to the biped skeleton and I had my
digital double of Sam doing a stunt that
would kill a regular stuntman mm-hmm
look great oh hi there special delivery
you know what do you know a new pair of
shorts to commemorate the ones I
exploded in our video yeah that's it
guys bye
you